ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนก็กลับมาเจอ
กับเรา 2 คนนั้นครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูฟ้าใน
วีดีโอระดับอะไรคะในวีดีโอระดับ
บีกินเนอร์ผ่านว่าไปกินเอ้อหานะคะค่ะใส่
แล้วครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันพฤหัสบดีที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพฤหัสที่ 10
ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคมอาจ
ปีพตอะไรคะมีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะมีข้อ 2 โทร 02  259
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
พุธค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9 ค่ะเดือนเดือน
นี้นะคมพี่พรรถ
2565 ปีคศ
2  0  2255 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่ง
นี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11 ค่ะ
ดีเดือนมีนาคม
มีผชศ. 2565 ปีคศ
022 ค่ะแล้วแต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
14:00 น
02:00 กี่นาทีคะอ่า
47 นาทีค่ะบ่าย 2 โมง 47 นาทีเนาะก็เป็น
เวลากลางวันตอนบ่ายนะคะเวลากลางวันนี้
ร้อนไหม
ร้อนมากนะคะผู้หญิง
ดื่มน้ำ
40 องศาน
รู้ยังไงล่ะ
ร้อนครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยร้อนเนี่ยไม่
ชอบไปชอบ
แตกมันออกเวลาร้อนเนี่ยเราจะอ่อไม่เอาไม่
ดีไม่ดีไม่ดีไม่ดีแต่เวลาร้อนเนี่ยที่
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยดีดี 1 อย่างคุณครูฟ้า
อากาศร้อนเวลาที่ร้อนที่ประเทศไทยร้อนมี
อะไรดีคะผู้หญิงเอ้า
มีผลไม้เยอะ
ๆ
มีผลไม้เยอะๆไม่มีสับปะรดมีทุเรียนมีอ่า
องุ่นมีมีกล้วยมีแอปเปิ้ลแอปเปิ้ลมีนิดมี
มีมีเยอะทุกวันนะคะมีมังคุดไหมตอนประเทศ
ไทยร้อนเนี่ยมีผลไม้
มากๆ
แล้วก็
ร้อนมีผลไม้มากๆใจทีเลยผู้หญิงเพราะผู้
ค้าดื่มน้ำนะดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำครับ
ไม่อยากลืมน้ำแล้วพี่ใช่มั้ยเวลาร้อนมี
ผลไม้เรากินผลไม้
อางอผลไม้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบ
ผลไม้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ห้ามวัดชอบกินคนละไม้มาก
ๆเห้ยอะไรแต่ผลไม้เนี่ยเวลาที่เรากิน
ผลไม้ใช้กินแล้วเนี่ย
เราก็จะแบบมึงอันนี้หวานงานผลไม้เนี่ยมี
หวานๆอย่างเช่นถ้าครูฟ้ากินสาลี่
สมัยสาลี่เนี่ย
ชาติเป็นยังไงคะเวลากูฟ้ากินสายรีบเวลา
กุมภากินสาลี่รถธาตุหวานค่ะอย่าวิ่ง
หวานนั้นนะคะๆแต่ถ้าครูฟ้ากินเสาวรสรอ
เสาวรสเนี่ยเวลากินเสาวรสรสชาติเป็นยังไง
มา
เที่ยวค่ะอยู่หน้าคือฟ้าด้วยเนี่ยเปรียว
[เพลง]
สาลี่เนี่ยหวานสมัยพาน
เสาวรสเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆแต่ถ้ากีวีหรอคะ
เวลาครูฟ้าเนี่ย
กินกีวี่กีวีเนี่ยหวานไหมหวานไอ้นิดโสฬส
นะไม่ใช่อันนี้สาริ
สาลี่แนวหวานกีวี่เนี่ยหวานเหมือนสาลี่
ไหม
ก็หวานนะ
แต่ว่าก็เปรี้ยวด้วย
คือกีวี่เนี่ยไม่ได้หวานร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์
เหมือนสาลี่ไม่ได้พริกโอ้เหมือนเสาวรส
แล้วเวลากินกี่ปีว่า
รสชาติเป็นยังไงอ่ะ
วันหวานๆเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวออกก็
เสาวรสแต่ไม่ใช่ขอโทษนักเรียนสาลิสาริคือ
กีวี่เนี่ยก็จะมีสาลี่
50% ใช่มั้ย
เราก็มีเสาวรส
50% ก็คือหวานหวานๆเปรี้ยวๆหวานเปรี้ยว
ถูกต้องครับผู้หญิง
สวยเพราะว่าเวลาเรากินผลไม้เนาะผลไม้นะคะ
เวลาเรากินผลไม้เนี่ยมันมันจะมีอยู่สามรส
ชาติสมัยก็คือแบบ
หวานน้องเหมือนสาลี่ใช่ไหมนี่นาหรือว่าลิ
โป้เหมือนเสาวรส
หรือหวานๆหวานๆเปรี้ยวๆร้านอาหารเหมือน
กีวี่
เดี๋ยววันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงก็จะมีรูปผลไม้
แล้วก็ให้ครูฟ้าบอกว่าเวลาที่เรากินเนี่ย
รสชาติเป็นยังไง
หวาน
เปรี้ยวหรือว่าหวานๆเปรี้ยวๆนะคะ
จะเป็นผลไม้ที่ไทยนะที่ประเทศไทยไว้ใส่
โอเคเลยอย่างแรกเลยค่ะส้มนักเวลาครูฟ้า
กินส้มรสชาติเป็นยังไงคะเวลาครูฟ้ากินส้ม
รสชาด
ริ้วๆ
เหมือนกีวี่ใช่ไหมส้มเหมือนกีวี่ใช่มั้ย
เค้าคือเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆหรือเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆๆ
ส้มโอล่าส้มโอเวลาครูฟ้ากินส้มโอว่ารส
ชาติเป็นยังไง
ต้องโอรสชาติเปรี้ยว
เปรี้ยวใช่ไหมเหมือนเสาวรส
เปรี้ยวโอเคก็แดงเนี่ย
ต่อไปค่ะกล้วยเวลาครูฟ้ากินกล้วยรสชาติ
เป็นยังไง
กล้วยเนี่ยรสชาติหวานค่ะครูหญิงหวาน
เหมือน
สาลี่นะหวานอันกล้วยก็จะหวานนะคะ
ชมพู่
เวลาครูฟ้ากินชมพู่รสชาติเป็นยังไง
เวลาฟ้ากินชมพู่รสชาติ
หรือเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆหรอหวานนะริ้วเปรี้ยวๆ
หวานๆ
เปรี้ยวหวาน
เปรี้ยวหวานเนื้อหาเวียนค่ะ
50%  50% ทรายค่ะอ่ะแอปเปิ้ลนะแอปเปิ้ล
สีแดงราคา Apple สีแดงเวลาครูฟ้ากิน
แอปเปิ้ลสีแดงรสชาติเป็นยังไง
แอปเปิ้ลสีแดงหวาน
กว่าหรอไม่รู้อันนี้นักเรียนรู้จักหรือ
เปล่านะคะลำไยลำไยเป็นผลไม้ไทยนะเนื้อสี
ขาวๆเวลาครูฟ้ากินลำไยรสชาติเป็นยังไงคะ
หวานใจของหวานอ่า
องุ่นอันนี้องุ่นประเทศไทยนะคะเวลาครูฟ้า
กินองุ่นรสชาติเป็นยังไงคะ
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวรี่เปรี้ยว
องุ่นไทยนะคะเปรี้ยวงูเที่ยวแล้วกะมีแตง
โมนะคะเวลาครูฟ้ากินแตงโมรสชาติเป็นยังไง
คะ
หวานหน้ากว่าสารซิลิกาเก
สับปะรดนะคะสับปะรดเวลาครูฟ้ากินสับปะรด
รสชาติเป็นยังไง
ขับปะรถเนี่ย
เปรี้ยวชอบเปรี้ยวใช่ไหมเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยว
มะม่วงนะคะเอาเอามะม่วงสีเหลืองนะมะม่วง
สุกนะคะมะม่วงสุกและสีเหลืองเวลาครูฟ้า
กินมะม่วงสุกสีเหลืองรสชาติเป็นยังไง
กว่าหวาน
รุ่นรุ่นเสียงหวาน
หวาน
ต่อไปนะคะขนุนขนุนขนุนสีเหลืองทำขนนเวลา
ครูฟ้ากินขนุนรสชาติเป็นยังไงคะกว่านห่า
กว่าเนาะกว่าลิ้นลิ้นจี่เวลาครูฟ้ากิน
ลิ้นจี่รสชาติเป็นยังไง
หวานค่ะกว่าหวาน
หวานเยอะเนาะ
อาหารครับทิมเวลาครูฟ้ากินทับทิมรสชาติ
เป็นยังไงคะ
หวานเหมือนกันกว่า
หวานหรอ
[เพลง]
ฝรั่ง
เวลาครูฟ้ากินฝรั่งรสชาติเป็นยังไง
น้าหรั่ง
รีบเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆนะคะน้ำ
ผลไม้ต่อไปนะคะเงาะเงาะใช่ไหมคะน้อเวลา
พรุ่งนี้ฟ้ากินเงาะรสชาติเป็นยังไง
หวานค่ะหวาน
ขวานไม่ใช่หวาน
อะไรนะว่าหวานหวนมากนะคะแต่ก็หวานเหรอ
มาละกอเวลาเครูบมะละกอสุกนะคะมาแล้วก็สี
ส้มๆเวลาครูฟ้ากินมะละกอรสชาติเป็นยังไง
หวานค่ะหวาน
หวาน
มังคุดมังคุดเวลาครูฟ้ากินมังคุดรสชาติ
เป็นยังไง
รสชาติ
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆไหมอ้าวสายกับ
เปรี้ยวๆหวานๆๆข้อต่อไปนะคะละมุดนะคะ
ละมุดเนี่ยเวลาครูฟ้ากินละมุดรสชาติเป็น
ยังไง
หวานค่ะหวาน
สตรอว์เบอร์รี่
ประเทศไทยเวลาครูฟ้ากินสตรอเบอรี่ประเทศ
ไทยรสชาติเป็นยังไง
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวมากนักเรียน
มาเฟืองนะคะมาเฟืองเวลาครูฟ้ากินมะเฟือง
รสชาติเป็นยังไง
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยว
อันนี้ก็เป็นผลไม้ไทยนะน้อยหน่านะคะ
น้อยหน่าเวลาครูฟ้ากินน้อยหน่ารสชาติเป็น
ยังไงแต่
ว่าเคยกินน้อยหนาว
หวาน
หวานมีฟ้าบอกกูฟังไม่เข้าใจน้อยหน่าหวาน
น้อยหน่าวางั้นอ้ะผลไม้สุดท้ายแล้วค่ะ
เชอรี่เวลาครูฟ้ากินเชอรี่รสชาติเป็นไง
เชอรี่ที่ไทยนะคะ
เธอกินเชอร์รี่ไทยนะไม่ไปถึงว่าแบบกินใน
ประเทศไทยนี่แหละเราซื้อประเทศไทยอ่ะว่า
นั้นหวานๆหลานชายค่ะเชอรี่หวานงั้นเรามา
ดูผลไม้ที่มีรสหวานใช่มั้ยเวลากินแล้วแบบ
หวานนะฮะก็จะมีอะไรคะคือฟ้า
เจอรี่ค่ะ
น้อยหน่า
ละมุด
เยอะนะเนี่ยมะละกอ
ขอ
งอ็อด
ทักทิม
ลิ้นจี่
ขนุน
มะม่วง
แตงโม
ลำไย
แอปเปิ้ลค่ะ
กล้วยแล้วก็
สาลี่น้องอันนี้เป็นผลไม้ที่มีรสหวาน
สไลด์เวลาเรากินเนาะเรามาดูผลไม้ที่มีรส
ผู้นะคะว่ามีอะไรบ้างอันนี้แหละกินแล้ว
แบบนี้เปรี้ยวนะคะ
มะเฟืองค่ะ
รอเบอร์รี่
สับปะรด
องุ่นส้ม
ถ้าไม่ใช่ก็ถ้ากูฟ้าอันนี้อันนี้อันนี้
โอ๊ะ
เสาวรสเสียงอันนี้เนี่ยเปรี้ยวนะคะต่อไป
เรามาดูผลไม้ที่เวลากินแล้วรสชาติเปรี้ยว
เปรี้ยวๆหวานๆแล้วก็จะมี
ต้มค่ะ
มังคุด
ฝรั่ง
ชมพู่
ดีวี่
กีวี่เนาะแล้วครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกิน
ผลไม้รสอะไรรสหวาน
รสเปรี้ยวหรือว่า
หวานอ่ะเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆคะ
ปลาชอบกินผลไม้
รสหวานค่ะ
กินผลไม้รสหวานอาบน้ำว่ะบางสุดนำบ้าน
number  one บ้านที่สุดผลไม้หวานนะคะ
แต่งจริงพ่อค้าชอบกินส้มนะ
ส้มอยู่นี่นะส้มเนี่ยเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวาน
ๆหน้ามันจะมีส้มที่หวานนะนักเรียนมีส้ม
แบบว่าหวานอันนั้นอ่ะฟ้าชอบมากแล้วแต่ว่า
ที่ไทยถ้าส้มคนไทยจะไม่ส้มกับเนี่ยสีแบบ
นี้มันจะเปรี้ยวๆหวานหวานมันแบบหวานก็มี
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆก็มีแต่แต่
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกินผลไม้รสหวานนะคะกฎหมาย
ที่รสชาติหวานอ่ะแล้วคุยหญิงชอบกินผลไม้
รสชาติอะไรคะผู้หญิงชอบกินผลไม้รสชาติ
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆค่ะแบบนี้อ่ะออก
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆส้มเงี้ยกีวี่ Smart
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆ
พรรคเผาอะไรขนาดนั้นคะผลไม้ที่มีรสชาติ
หวานอ่าเหมือนครูฟ้าบอกมันจะมีหวานใช่ไหม
คะกล้วยเนี่ยหวานอ่าแอปเปิ้ลเนี่ยหวานแต่
ลำไยเนี่ย
กว่าหวาน
หวานมากๆค่ะ
ตั้งโมงหนูก็หวานธรรมดาเนาะแล้วก็จะมีอีก
อย่างหนึ่งก็คือที่มันหวานมากๆค่ะมี 2
อย่างนะคือความทีอันนี้กูก็ไม่เคยกินเงาะ
ใช่ไหมคะเงาะเหมือนลำไยนะ
มากๆ
แล้วก็อันนี้ปูปลาไม่เคยกินนะคะน้อยหน่า
น้อยหน่ามีแต่ก็บอกหวานมากๆ
แล้วก็อย่างนึงอะไรคะ
ละมุดใช่ไหมคะประมุทเนี่ยก็หวานนะอันนี้
เนี่ยผลไม้หวานใช่มั้ยเวลากินแล้วมีรส
หวานมันก็จะหวานแล้วก็หวานมากๆ
ว่าผู้หญิงชอบผลไม้อะไรมากที่สุดก็หมาย
ที่กูหญิงชอบ
ผู้หญิงบอกว่าผู้หญิงชอบ
เปรี้ยวๆหวานๆใช่ไหมจริงผู้หญิงชอบผลไม้
ที่คุณชอบมากที่สุดก็คือ
มัลเบอรี่หรอ
มัลเบอรี่ไม่ใช่ของไทยไม่ใช่ของไทยเพราะ
ว่ามัลเบอรี่แหละมันจะแบบเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆ
หวานหวานๆ
แล้วครูฟ้าล่ะครูฟ้าชอบผลไม้อะไรมากที่
สุด
แต่
ลูกค้าชอบ
ไอเดีย
ต้มปลาชอบส้มตำฟ้าชอบส้มที่หวานนะคะไม่
ใช่ส้มที่เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆหรอไม่ได้
ชอบผลไม้หลายอย่างยิ่งจ่ายค่ะจริงๆผู้
หญิงถ้าผลไม้ไทยเนี่ยผู้หญิงชอบอันนี้คือ
ฟ้า
แตงโม
ออกแต่แตงโมเนี่ยมันหวานมันหวาน
[เพลง]
ผลไม้ที่เปรี้ยวๆหวานๆครีมชอบมัลเบอรี่
มัลเบอรี่ใส่ค่ะแล้วนักเรียนนอทชอบผลไม้
รสชาติอะไรหวานนะคะ
เปรี้ยวหรือว่าเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆก็
พี่เบนซ์บอกเค้าได้นะคะสวยวันนี้เราสองคน
ก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้า
เนาะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ